CARL, DID YOU EAT ALL
THE CINNAMON TOAST CRUNCH?
- HOLD IT.
SHUT UP FOR A SECOND.
- CARL?
- HEY, YOU KNOW WHAT
I JUST REALIZED
IS AWESOME ABOUT GOOGLE?
GOOGLE'S NAME SPELLED BACKWARDS
IS THE SAME
AS ITS NAME IN SPANISH.
- ELGOOG?
- THAT'S BRANDING ON
A WHOLE OTHER LEVEL, MAN.
LIKE 3-D CHECKERS AND SHIT.
- ELGOOG.
- GOOGLE'S ALL POWERFUL!
THERE'S NOTHING GOOGLE
CAN'T GOOGLE.
- I COULD STUMP THE GOOG.
- [scoffs]
IF ANYBODY'S GONNA STUMP
THE GOOG, IT'S GONNA BE ME.
- OH, YEAH?
- OH, YEAH.
- YOU'RE ON.
both: STUMP THE GOOG!
[acid guitar]
- AND WE'RE IN.
- YEAH, ME FIRST.
GOOGLE A MONKEY RAPING
A SOCK MONKEY.
- [screeching]
- [laughing]
OH, YOU'RE WELCOME!
- GOOGLE CATACORN.
- [meow]
- OKAY, GOOGLE A MONKEY
RAPING A BANANA.
- WHAT IS WITH YOUR
MONKEY RAPING THING?
- [screeching]
OKAY, LET'S DANCE.
CLOWN DOING LAUNDRY.
- CELEBRITY COLONOSCOPIES.
- MEXICAN LEPRECHAUN.
- PIÑATAS GONE WILD.
- WOOKIE NOOGIE.
- EROTIC SHRUBBERY.
- MIDGET NINJAS WHO ALSO MIME.
- QUADRIPLEGIC STRIPPER.
- URINE BLOWBACK.
- ASS CARPET.
- SEXY JESUS.
- PLATY [bleep].
- FICUS FLIGHT CLUB.
- SHARDS OF GLASS-CICLE.
- PUBE OF THE MONTH CLUB.
- SACK-O-LANTERN.
- GOLLUM ON VACATION.
- EJACULA.
- TAMPON TEA.
- MUPPETS GETTIN' BUSY.
- FRUIT PORN!
- JESUS, DUDE.
OH, I GOT ONE!
MOVE.
A MONKEY RAPING--OW!
- GREETINGS, MY FRIENDS.
DO YOU MIND IF I UPLOAD MYSELF?
I AM ELGOOG,
KEEPER OF THE GOOGLE.
[retches]
- WHAT THE [bleep]?
- OH, GOD.
- I MUST INSIST
THE TWO OF YOU--HOW DO YOU SAY?
CUT THE SHIT.
THE GOOGLE IS NOT A TOY.
IT IS A TOOL
TO BE USED RESPONSIBLY
TO ACCESS INFORMATION,
AND, OF COURSE,
FOR THE BOOBIES.
IT IS NOT FOR YOU TWO DIPSHITS
TO GOOGLE WILLY-NILLY.
- HEY, THIS IS AMERICA,
GOOGLE LARD ASS,
AND I DON'T RECALL GOOGLING
SEÑOR BABY FAT [bleep] FACE.
WE DIDN'T, DID WE, ANU?
- NO, BUT MAYBE WE SHOULD.
GOOGLE ELGOOG.
- NO, NO.
YOU CANNOT GOOGLE THE GOOGLE!
I COMMAND YOU TO STOP!
[yelling]
[boom]
- ANU.
- WHAT?
- I DID EAT ALL
THE CINNAMON TOAST CRUNCH.
[telephone rings]